they're rebooting all these shows now  the big shows from from the 90s and  there's there's talk about I guess this  talk about a mad about you and of course  you were  Ursula on that show and I was curious  and Ursula is his sister of maybe yeah  she's the twins twin sister of Phoebe  from friends so this brings up the  question if there's a mad about you  reunion would you and they said hey  could you come back and be Ursula would  you do that I mean I don't know I guess  she'd have to she's just an older idiot  yeah that's really your summing up the  whole character yeah yeah yeah but I  think it might be fun it'll just  especially if you didn't have to do it  all the time right it's right going to  do like a guest star thing that's my  requirement now as long as I have to do  it all the time right and no tropical  fish are involved yeah and no travel  yeah and no travel you what made it work  somebody yeah  you